depuis le début de la campagne
électorale le npd répète cette
affirmation car les questions de
changement climatique
just you know the honey rider avec jc
revenez chez vous in christie machine
aux deux sections 6 bennett est ce que
le canada est vraiment le seul pays du
groupe des sept ou les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre ont grimpé dans les
dernières années
[Musique]
c'est vrai les émissions ont bel et bien
augmenté depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir de
justin trudeau mais pas dans les autres
pays du g7
en 2015 on a racheté 723 mégatonnes de
gaz à effet de serre aux pays
s'abaisser à 707 mégatonnes l'année
suivante et puis ça recommence à grimper
on a atteint 730 négateur de grs en 2019
un niveau plus élevé qu'au moment de
l'entrée en poste de libéro
selon les dernières données disponibles
le royaume uni l'allemagne la france le
japon l'italie et les états unis ont
tous réussi à réduire leurs émissions le
canada est donc le seul pays du g7 qui
va dans la mauvaise direction
au printemps ottawa s'est fixé une
nouvelle cible dans le cadre de l'accord
de paris sur les changements climatiques
réduire de 40% les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre par rapport aux niveaux
de 2005 pour y arriver le canada va
devoir trancher
295 mégatonnes de grs son bilan carbone
en raison de la pandémie les émissions
mondiales ont chuté en 2020 mais les
experts s'attendent à un rebond
important en 2021